okay today I'm going to talk to you
about balancing equations using masses
we're going to have a look at this
question here and how to write a
balanced equation
giving this information so the question
says Paula burns a metal X in oxygen so
this is just an unknown metal this X
there is a single product an oxide of
the element given that twenty five point
four grams of X burns in 3.2 grams of
oxygen write a balanced equation we're
also given information about the atomic
mass of X and the relative formula mass
of the oxide so it seems quite complex
we're going to do the step by step
process of how to figure it out so the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm just
going to try and summarize this
information with a basic equation not
balanced yet which is the basic equation
so I've got the idea of X is reacting
with oxygen which is o2 to form an oxide
of X so just by writing this simple idea
out I've got in my head what's going on
these are reacting together to give this
so my next step what I have to do is I'm
just going to write down the other
information I have about the masses so I
know I've got twenty five point four
grams of X and 3.2 grams of oxygen so
just underneath each one so I know what
which mass is applying to which one I'm
just going to write them underneath 3.2
grams so my next step is this if I start
off with 25.4 grams of this and 3.2
grams of this the mass of the oxide
produced must be the sum of these two so
I need to add them together to find the
mass of that because no atoms are
created or destroyed the mass of the
reactants must add up to the masses of
the product so this is 28.6 grams so now
I've got the mass of each of these what
I'm trying to do now is I'm trying to
find the number of moles so I can use
this equation triangle here this comes
in handy a lot of the time when we're
using moles so M stands for mass which
is measured in grams
n stands for the number of moles so
that's just the number of particles
reacting and M R stands for relative
formula mass now this could also stand
for relative atomic mass depending on
what we're talking about so what I'm
going to do first of all is I'm going to
try and find the relative sorry the
number of moles of X right here so to
find the number of moles I need to be
the mass divided by the relative formula
mass so in this particular instance I'm
going to do the mass 25.4 divided by the
relative formula mass of this now the
relative formula mass is given right
here I'm told what it is right here so
it's going to be twenty five point four
so I just get my calculator twenty five
point four divided by sixty three point
five and the answer is zero point four
so the number of moles of this is zero
point four now I'm gonna do the exact
same for this so to find a number of
moles of oxygen of o2 I need to do the
mass divided by the relative formula
mass say 3.2 divided by now because I'm
not given this information I have to use
my periodic table so the relative atomic
mass of oxygen is 16 so because there's
two of them
it's going to be divided by 16 times 2
or simplified that's three point two
divided by 32 because that is what 16
times 2 is so 3.2 divided by 32 is zero
point one so that is the mass the number
of moles of that one
and finally for my oxide of X is the
number of moles again use this equation
try with a master vital rated formula
mass so my mass is there that I've
already worked out twenty eight point
six and I need to divide it by the
relative formula
again I'm given that number here 143 so
I'm dividing it by a hundred and forty
three so I'm gonna use my calculator my
twenty eight point six / 143 is zero
point two so for my next step you might
be able to basically what we need to do
next to see the ratio between these
different numbers instantly you might be
able to see it so for example you might
be able to see that zero point four two
zero point one two 0.2
to two ratio however if these numbers
aren't as kind as this what you can do
is this you find the smallest number of
the three and you divide each one by the
smallest number so let's just quickly do
that so to find this one you need to do
0.4 divided by 0.1 and that equals four
for this one you need to do 0.1 divided
by 0.1 which equals one and for this one
you do 0.2 divided by 0.1 which equals
two so all I've done to each of these is
divide by the smallest number so four to
one to two ratio that's going to tell me
how what numbers need to go in front of
each of these in order to balance the
equation so now I'm nearly done so I'm
gonna look at the kind of rough equation
that I've written here in order to sort
me out so I know that there's going to
be four atoms of this so it's gonna be
4x I also know I'm gonna have 102
because this number here is 402 notice
how with all of my calculations I've
written them exactly underneath each one
so not to get confused so I've got 102
I'm just gonna write that as Oh - now
the next bit is to find the formula of
this oxide now I know for a metal oxide
it's gonna be X and O now I don't know
how many X's they're going to be they'll
know how many O's they're gonna be yet
but I know that there's going to be a
two and four
of it because I've got this number right
here it's showing I've got to lots of my
metal oxide so all I need to do now is
figure out how many X's I have and how
many O's I have to do that I need to
make sure it's balanced to this side of
the equation so I know I've got four X's
so if I've got a two in front of here I
know I must have two lots of X to make
four in total on the left-hand side of
the equation my reactants I've got two
oxygen atoms now because there's a two
in front of here I know I've already got
my correct number of oxygens so I don't
need to put a little number here so as a
result that is the balance symbol
equation right there 4x plus o2 goes to
2 X - OH
so that is how to balance equations
using masses thank you